The Next Step
which is really the last step we are
going to go ahead and deploy this
application using the RS connect python
package
now there's a note right here you will
need to create and use an API key in
order to deploy your python application
and this is important because when you
deploy to posit Connect using this
package the RS connect python package
connect needs to know who's actually
trying to deploy and make sure you have
the necessary credentials and the
Privileges to actually deploy to that
instance of posit connect
so right here is the command that we're
going to use to deploy our dash
application I'm going to go ahead and
copy it
bring it on over to vs code again
running in posit workbench and just
paste it I'm not going to run it just
yet but let's run through this command
because it reads pretty easily from left
to right
so we're using that RS connect python
package so this uh function right here
to deploy a dash application to This
Server this instance of posit connect
and then you can see this next argument
API key and then there's some
placeholder text right here
so this is where you're going to supply
that API key to let connect know that
hey it's me deploying this dash
application to that instance of posit
connect
so where do we find this API key
let's go back to posit connect which
I've already logged into I'm going to
close out of this jumpstart example
because we're pretty much done with it
for the most part
and I'm going to go over here to the my
name in the top right corner
and you'll see API keys so you can click
on API keys and you can see I've already
created about four or so API keys if you
need to create a brand new one you just
select this box right here copy that API
key come on back over to vs code running
a pause at workbench and paste it right
here
Now API Keys you should always treat
just like you would any passwords you
want to make sure they're nice and safe
I've actually already added this to my
environment so I'm just going to delete
this argument
and the RS connect python package will
automatically detect it when it runs
this command
and then the last little bit this Dot
and then the the forward slash right
here it RS connect will automatically
detect this app.pi application in the
directory and deploy it so that's it
this is the command we'll hit enter and
we'll let it run
so it looks like I may have so let me
just check the print working directory
I'm gonna try to come out one more time
oh I got delete the API key there we go
and hit enter
there we go so it's going through a few
checks right here like validating the
server making sure that bundle looks
good everything seems to be in order
okay if anything's not in order it
should print some nice useful messages
for you to help troubleshoot
but what's actually happening right now
like when you deploy this application
what's going on
so for the most part it's capturing my
environment it's looking to see what
python version am I using what libraries
am I using what versions of the library
so you can see like right here for
example all these various python
libraries and their Associated versions
it's making sure connect has those
packages and the appropriate versions on
the server and can replicate my
environment exactly as it's laid out
here
once it's established it can it then
deploys that duplicate dash application
so you can see deployment completed
successfully
and then it gives me two links right
here we'll select that top one
click on this
and it's going to bring us right to
posit connect
and while this is running kind of
setting up right here you'll notice as a
publisher I have this little gear icon
in the top right corner and these are
some additional controls I have as a
publisher of this Dash application
but here it is this is the dash
application now hosted on posit connect